okay so House of the Dragon is almost at
the halfway point and the new promo for
episode 5 hints at one of the major
events coming in the entry it's a nice
day for a red wedding and the upcoming
episode looks like it's gonna have [ __ ]
kicking off throughout this video we're
going to be talking about what happens
in the books where we think the
characters are going to be heading and
much much more because of this there
will be heavy heavy spoilers oh my God
they are so heavy so if you don't want
the series potentially ruined then I
recommend that you turn off now if you
enjoyed the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
every day by the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into house
of the Dragon episode 5.
I wish to propose a marriage
my daughter an heir
a royal wedding
I hope to Herald in a second age of
dragons
knives will come out now we start off
with several ships sailing towards the
red keep and also two dragons in the sky
later when we catch a look at the sails
on the boats we can see that there's a
white seahorse showing that this belongs
to the valerians therefore I think that
this being tied to a wedding gives us a
big clue about what's going on you might
remember that earlier in the season
viserys decided to go with an older
woman I guess and he married the young
Allison instead of corliss's daughter
Elena they spin the Sea Lord and we
discovered that he'd proposed a wedding
with his daughter and one of the rulers
of braavos this will cause a lot of
issues with the realm and in the book a
similar thing happened therefore in
order to try and bury the hatchet Osiris
arranged for Rainier to get married to
corliss's son lanor who we last saw in
episode 3. he was the one riding the
Silver Dragon sea smoke and he's also
the next in line to inherit everything
that call his owns therefore this Union
would marry the houses together and
basically make it so that viserys
prevented a war whilst also writing the
wrong of the past we see the wedding
celebrations and I even think that we
might get a glimpse at mushroom if
you've watched our videos and you'll
know we've talked about him a lot and
how he was basically a Jester that
gossiped about things that he saw the
books had him being the person that
spread the rumors about rhaenyra and
Damon sleeping together so I'm really
hoping that he becomes a character in
the show now these rumors are also
another reason why viz wanted Ray to
marry as quickly as possible as it would
stamp out any descent amongst the people
the two houses being married would also
likely produce an heir and this would
cause major problems down the line this
is something that rhaenys touches upon
and the reason that there'd be so many
problems is because we of course now
know that there are people who think
aegon should be the next king their
being two heirs would likely cause a lot
of conflict amongst the kingdoms and
likely mean that it would split the
entire realm into a civil war in the
books this comes to take place as well
and it's known as The Greens versus
blacks the greens are the high towers
and throughout the series we've seen as
Alison has worn the color the blacks are
the targaryens and the the book say that
this color is significant to them
because the family of course wear red
and black it was actually at this
wedding that the two sides started to
fracture and it was said that there was
a major tournament held to celebrate the
event the dragons of the opposing sides
apparently started snapping at each
other and the greens and blacks started
to take formation there are other
characters that join them too with us
hearing talk of people trying to seize
the throne this includes the Lannisters
and we watch both Thailand and Jason
enter what I believe is the throne room
the letter of course astroneera to marry
him and he might feel rejected by this
and try and seize power when things are
weak in the book Thailand asked to marry
her as well and he also got dismissed
too I think they're skipping over that
though which I have mentioned before and
he's probably just going to be the
master of coin like what we see from his
uniform here you also catch Kristen Cole
being mentioned amongst this as well you
can see that the person he's talking to
is Alison and the wedding actually
caused him to side with her at the
tournament Christian ended up beating
the crap out of Harwin strong and you
also massively [ __ ] up your free
lawnmouth who ended up dying from his
wounds though it was a tournament this
caused a lot of people to turn against
Kristin and this was when Alison got him
on her side he was really annoyed that
ranero was going through with the
wedding because he had feelings for her
and the ceremony pushed him into siding
with Alison over here I can definitely
see that being part of the show as well
they've sort of created this love
triangle with him in it that's likely
gonna push him over the edge seems to be
fighting at the wedding in one of the
shots I think this might be the event
that causes everyone to turn on him
the king will die a different era
succeeds him war will follow
prepare egg on to rule
and the next big thing is Otto saying
that the king will die we catch him in
front of his model of all Valeria and
his metaphorically shows how he's doomed
just like it was in The Legend it was a
great Dragon Kingdom that eventually
ended up being destroyed in a volcanic
eruption this was known as doom and it's
similar how Pompeii played out for the
citizens of it in real life aegon then
traveled from here and conquered six of
the Seven Kingdoms while that Valeria is
very much seen as the end of an era
similar to what could be happening with
viserys also look at his look at his
armya be insane for weeks that he had
grayscale then I went against it because
everyone kicked off I don't know if I'm
back on the Mephisto train with it or
not but come on here look look at his
arm it does look like grayscale that
doesn't it come on give me that one
thing along with a like now we also see
him collapsing whilst Allison looks over
the courtyard and I kind of think that
this guy isn't Gonna Last too many more
episodes I did tell you there would be
book spoilers but yeah I'm gonna give
you another chance to exit the video if
you don't want to know what happens with
him he's still here
cool well just checking you're gone yeah
cool so you've probably already figured
out that he's gonna die soon and the
character does indeed pass away he ends
up dying from an unknown illness and
this causes an event known as the dance
of the Dragons it's basically a name for
the Civil War where everyone fights it
out for the throne and it completely
splits all the houses
Otto sort of touches upon this and he is
of course aware that the death of beers
will put this into play if aegon doesn't
get the throne then the entire thing
with his daughter Alice and has been for
nothing and they have failed this is why
he pushes her into making sure it's the
case and why she likely tries to get
Kristen now speaking of deaths we also
get a big one in who I believe is Lady
rear towards the end of the trailer we
see a woman with brown hair falling
backwards whilst her horse jumps up in
the book Rio was badly injured whilst
she was out horse riding and she fell
from her ride and cracked her head off a
stone it's caused her to be bedridden
for several days though eventually she
got up however she ended up collapsing
and this was the end of her damn and
then flew to the veil in order to try
and gain power but he was denied by the
rest of the family the veil is an area
that's part of in Game of Thrones before
and you'll fall in love with it if you
ever go there now in the book this was
just one big accident but the series
might be changing things up if you look
closely to the left of the horse you can
see that there's a figure there and this
is wearing a long gray cloak showing
that someone probably scared it it's
what Damon also wore whilst he was
taking runira out on the town making me
think that it's 100 him you also have a
shot in the teaser of Damon wearing this
cloak and he's standing in this
environment since he wore last week and
was exiled I think he's then traveled
out of the veil and then killed her
Damon was of course married to Lady rear
and he could be carrying out the murder
in order to try and gain power The Merc
said that he was exiled from the kingdom
so this might be a last-ditch attempt by
him in order to try and gain some land
he does do other things in the book I
think that this is the first step the
whole thing with real living for several
days after this event could also cause
lot of trouble for him if they have
indeed switched it up she could end up
saying that he was the one who did it
and they might divert heavily from The
Source material I didn't think we'd
actually get rare in the series due to
her dying off screen well not off screen
but you know what I mean in the original
work and it makes Damon even more evil
if he's willing to murder his wife just
to gain some power and who knows what
the guy is gonna do next either way
that's everything we could spot in the
trailer and let us know below if you
noticed anything yourself we're running
a competition right now giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of September and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our Brighton of episode 4 which will
be linked on screen right now we talk
about all the book similarities what you
need to know about the characters and
definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video know I'll be
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace